[Music]
good evening and welcome to tucker
carlson tonight picture this
you're sitting eating dinner in a
restaurant with some of your friends on
a friday night
you're deep into conversation when in
the distance you hear shouting
you look up and you see a group of
demonstrators walking down the street
yelling and holding flags that say black
lives matter
the group is loud but you don't have a
problem with what you think they are
saying
of course black lives matter you agree
with that completely it seems obvious to
you
you're against racism you've never
mistreated anyone because of his race
you're not a bad person
so at first it doesn't occur to you that
this mob of angry people
might be angry at you why would they be
but then suddenly the mob is there at
your table
screaming in your face throwing chairs
smashing glasses sweeping cutlery to the
floor
threatening to kill you within seconds
you're running for your life
that happens in our country now it
happened this weekend in rochester
here's what it looked like
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
if you don't give us
[Music]
oh
get out of here
what are those people eating dinner in
rochester do wrong
no one ever said no one ever does or how
about this elderly couple in pittsburgh
they tried to get something to drink in
an outdoor cafe
over the weekend watch what happened
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
if you old man screams the blm protester
and gives him the finger
a female protester strides up and
guzzled the old woman's drink
why because she can the ultimate
humiliation
so what exactly did the elderly couple
do to deserve the abuse you just saw
what was their crime
if you listen to blm you know the answer
they live in america
they work and pay taxes they support a
system that
systematically murders people in effect
their war criminals
guards in the world's largest
concentration camp that's blm's position
increasingly it is the position of the
democratic party and the position of our
compliant news media
you hear it everywhere what's amazing is
how
cynical it is people who say this don't
even pretend to believe it
they ignore their own slogans if you
really thought america was a white
supremacist
dystopia a place where people of color
get murdered just for going outdoors
as the democratic platform suggests is
true
then you probably wouldn't encourage
millions of non-white immigrants to move
here
you'd be too worried about their safety
bringing people from africa for example
would be tantamount to premeditated
murder you wouldn't want that on your
conscience
of course in real life it's all fake the
opposite is true in fact
africans thrive in this country nigerian
immigrants the united states earn more
money on average than native born
americans
nigerian immigrants are also more likely
to get college degrees than people who
grew up here
if what blm is telling us is true
how could this happen well because
they're lying
for the overwhelming majority of lower
income americans
melanin is not the main barrier to
advancement
education and social class are for poor
people the main problem
is money it always has been they don't
have enough of it their kids have even
less
this is pretty obvious if you think
about it if you look at the numbers
but a ruling class doesn't want you to
think about it they don't want to have
that conversation they don't want to
talk about economics because they fear
it might cost them something
so instead they promote race conflict in
order to divert our attention from their
theft
these riots have very little to do with
racial oppression
look at who's rioting do they look
oppressed to you
last week the nypd arrested a group of
people at a demonstration held by a
group called the new african black
panther party
that's afrikan with a k to suggest
maximum revolutionary fervor
here on the screen you'll see the
mugshots the people who got arrested in
new york
the first thing you'll notice while they
were representing what they called the
new african black panther party
none of these people is african they
look like affluent american kids in fact
and indeed they are one of them is the
daughter of an architect and a child
psychiatrist in manhattan
she's got a second home in connecticut
another is a fine arts major who used to
work for pepsi
his last known address was a high income
neighborhood in florida
another one of the rioters spent his
summers jetting back and forth to europe
another has a modeling contract yet
another is a student at a place called
sarah lawrence university
that's a holding pen for the dimmer
offspring of our leadership class
that school costs almost 60 000 a year
if you go online you can find pictures
of this young committed revolutionary
singing show tunes at her local yacht
club on long island
so these kids are not impressed it's
likely none of them have ever met
an oppressed person except maybe on
junior year abroad
so why are they breaking things and
hurting people because they've been
brainwashed into hating our country and
hating themselves
by corrupt education establishment
they're also decadent and bored like so
many pampered children
after half a year of authoritarian
lockdowns they're looking for something
more interesting to do than getting high
and watching netflix
and also for many of them underneath it
all they are frustrated and rightly
so by vanishing economic opportunity
they sense correctly they will never be
as successful as their parents
generation
for them the american dream has died so
they no longer believe in america
all of that combined probably accounts
for the radicalism you're watching
but we don't need to know that because
we don't need to understand why rioters
riot in order to oppose
rioting we should always oppose rioting
no matter what is justification
these are the forces of chaos and
destruction they're working to tear down
our country that's all we need to know
if we care about our families and our
civilization about the future of our
descendants we have got to fight them
like everything depended on it
because everything does depend on it
when compared with the suppression of
anarchy teddy roosevelt once told the
congress
every other question sings innocent
insignificance
the anarchist is the enemy of humanity
the enemy of all mankind
his is a deeper degree of criminality
than any other
roosevelt wrote that in 1908 it was just
seven years after an anarchist
assassinated the president of the united
states william mckinley
he was roosevelt's running mate in some
ways 1908
isn't so different a period in american
history as the one we're living through
right now
in 1908 america was fast becoming an
unstable country
mass immigration had made the society
far less cohesive
new technology completely upended the
way people lived and the way they worked
there was a recession underway in 1908
coupled with high unemployment
people were angry at the banks at big
business angry at capitalism itself
and there was also racial unrest during
one race riot in 1908 in springfield
illinois
mobs burned buildings and attacked
citizens in their homes more than a
dozen people
died 1908 was a chaotic moment
so not surprisingly some people became
radical they called themselves
anarchists they believed in violence in
february of that year an anarchist shot
a priest to death during communion at
church
in denver he cited no reason for doing
it
he just said he hated christianity a few
weeks later another anarchist tried to
assassinate the chief of police of
chicago
at his home later that month anarchists
staged a deadly riot in a park in
manhattan
one of them threw a bomb at police
officers quote i came to the park to
kill police he later said
i hate them throughout 1908 there was at
least
one anarchist bombing every month of the
year in the city of new york
sound familiar to you then as now
the radical left leveraged economic
anxiety to force their program on
america
anarchists attacked cops and clergy in
public buildings
precisely because these were the symbols
of permanence and authority
they were the symbols of power greater
than the mob so they must be destroyed
the anarchist goal was to topple the
nation itself
teddy roosevelt knew that he understood
that systems that tolerate anarchy don't
last
long if mobs are allowed to attack the
police
why do i have to pay taxes why do i have
to obey traffic laws
or for that matter obey the fda or the
epa or the local health department or
anyone else who claims to be in charge
people
quickly start thinking like that when
anarchists
are allowed to have their way and why
wouldn't they think like that
once they do things fall apart fast
society itself was at stake in 1908 as
it is now and teddy roosevelt understood
it
our leaders democratic leaders don't
understand that
or more likely they don't care chaos
serves their purposes
consider barack obama obama is a smart
man he's a very gifted speaker
many people found him inspiring and it's
understandable why
but when the fog lifted after obama's
eight years in
office what was left a dying middle
class
a nation more radically divided by race
and by income
a population so hostile to their
political leaders
that they elected donald trump president
by any measure barack obama left a wake
of destruction behind him
in the end one of the relatively few who
prospered was barack obama himself
obama and his wife became unimaginably
wealthy legitimately rich
with huge estates in different parts of
the country where did barack obama get
all that money
no one asks we're too busy hating each
other
obama stokes that hatred because it
helps him here he is the democratic
convention this summer
americans of all races joining together
to declare
in the face of injustice
and brutality at the hands of the state
that black lives matter no more
but no less to the young people who led
us this summer telling us we need to be
better
in so many ways you are this country's
dreams fulfilled
the young people who led us this summer
it's hard to believe barack obama said
that obama has an internet connection he
sees the news
he knows that the same young leaders he
is promoting on stage
burned buildings looted stores murdered
people
obama is smart enough to know that what
the mobs are doing
isn't bringing people together just the
opposite riots don't heal
wounds they create them the violence
that barack obama's youth brigades have
unleashed on this country if anything
increased racial bigotry and distrust
the riots have certainly accelerated
residential segregation
as higher income people flee the
racially diverse cities
for sedate monochromatic destinations
like martha's vineyard where by the way
barack obama himself
lives like any good arsonist obama was
sure to exit the building before he lit
the fire
someday obama and many leaders like him
may flee farther than that
an island off the coast of massachusetts
won't be far enough they'll be in
switzerland by then or
austria or new zealand or somewhere
where they won't have to live with the
consequences of the society that they
created
but for the rest of us who plan to stay
we have no choice
we have to fight anarchism goes by many
names right now it's called
antifa and blm but the poison
is always the same and the consequences
of imbibing it never change
if we're going to survive as a country
we must defeat this